Revisore: Nicoletta Pedrana
Dice George Bernard Shaw
che se io ho una mela,
ed un'altra persona ha una mela,
e ce la scambiamo,
al termine dello scambio
entrambi abbiamo una mela in mano;
ma se io ho un'idea,
e la scambio con un'altra persona,
al termine di questo scambio
entrambi abbiamo due idee.
Vi racconto questa frase
perché secondo me riassume benissimo
tutto quello che è Wikipedia.
Perché c'è lo scambio,
la gratuità, il confronto
e tutto sommato c'è anche l'apertura.
Wikipedia è un progetto
che nasce nel 2001,
e a differenza di quello
che molti immaginano,
non è un'opera prima.
Non è che un signore
si è svegliato una mattina e ha detto:
"Faccio Wikipedia, e vediamo come viene".
In realtà un anno prima
era stata creata Nupedia,
che era un'enciclopedia
con caratteristiche simili
a quelle che ritroviamo in Wikipedia:
ossia era gratuita,
era liberamente accessibile,
potevano essere riutilizzati i contenuti;
ma era scritta unicamente da esperti,
quindi delle persone che fossero
o dei professori universitari
o degli esperti riconosciuti
nella materia,
o avessero almeno un dottorato di ricerca.
Le persone come me, ad esempio,
non avrebbero mai potuto
collaborare a Nupedia.
Forse ci avrebbero permesso di fare
un po' di operazioni tecniche
di manutenzione,
correzioni dell'italiano
e della formattazione, ma nulla di più.
Nupedia ricalcava un poco
quello che era l'editoria scientifica,
per cui al suo interno aveva
un processo di peer review molto complesso
che constava di sette passi.
Questa complessità ha fatto sì
che nel primo anno di vita Nupedia
abbia pubblicato unicamente 25 articoli,
che erano decisamente pochi.
Quindi nell'anno successivo
hanno pensato di rivedere
un pochino questo progetto
e di creare il cosiddetto
"parente povero",
un'enciclopedia che prendesse
quelli che erano
i punti di chiusura di Nupedia
e li facesse diventare
dei punti di apertura,
per cui hanno tolto
quelle che erano le barriere all'ingresso
per la stesura di un contenuto
e hanno tolto anche quello che era
il processo di peer review interno,
per cui eliminato
un processo in sette passi,
e tutto quello che veniva
scritto sul progetto
andava immediatamente on-line.
Questa incredibile apertura
ha avuto un successo strepitoso,
perché nel primo anno
l'edizione in inglese di Wikipedia
ha pubblicato circa 10.000 voci,
che erano tantissime,
se pensate che stiamo parlando del 2001
e che le persone
che navigavano in Internet
erano molte meno di quelle
che ci sono al giorno d'oggi.
Nello stesso anno, grosso modo a maggio,
di fianco all'edizione in inglese
sono state create
un'altra decina di edizioni,
tra cui l'edizione in italiano.
Io ho incontrato Wikipedia
solo nel maggio del 2003,
abbastanza per caso;
leggevo una newsletter
e si parlava di alcuni
progetti alternativi
o, insomma, diversi dal solito:
uno era OpenCola e l'altro era Wikipedia,
ma parlavano unicamente
dell'edizione in inglese.
Navigando sul sito
dell'edizione in inglese,
ho scoperto che esisteva
un'edizione in italiano,
e ho fatto un giro:
e una delle cose che mi ha incuriosito
era una voce che era scritta
a metà in italiano e metà in inglese
e sembrava chiaramente
una traduzione abbandonata a metà.
Guardando questa voce, ad un certo punto,
in alto c'è un link che diceva "Edit"
E io, non sapendo bene cosa fosse,
come giustamente bisogna fare
ci ho cliccato sopra;
e mi è comparso il testo della voce
in una casella
in cui io potevo modificarlo,
quindi ha tradotto una frase
per vedere un po' cosa poteva succedere.
Traduco la mia frase,
schiaccio "Salva", la vedo,
è già pubblicata e penso:
"No, vabbè, ma sarà come i forum,
che quando non sei registrato
magari puoi commentare,
però poi passa da un moderatore;
quindi adesso la vedo perché sono io,
mi riconosce, la sta cacheando,
c'è un cookie o cose del genere,
per cui aspetta un pochino".
Refresho, è la mia cosa è ancora lì,
però mi sembra ancora molto assurdo,
quindi chiudo il browser,
ne apro un altro,
torno a vedere ed era ancora lì.
Questa cosa mi ha colpito incredibilmente
perché è straordinaria,
o quantomeno diversa
da qualsiasi altra cosa
che io avessi sperimentato
fino a quel momento.
Il web non era fatto in quel modo;
io, se navigavo in rete,
al più potevo lasciare i miei commenti,
potevo offrire le mie idee,
ma in maniera molto diretta.
E il fatto che io potessi modificare
qualcosa che era stato scritto
da qualcun altro, direttamente,
lasciarlo disponibile anche alla modifica
di qualcun altro dopo di me,
era una cosa che mi ha stupito moltissimo.
E così ho iniziato a collaborare
a questo strano progetto
e a scoprire che in realtà
quello che stavamo creando
era un progetto,
ma era anche un micromondo,
era un po' una nuvola di contenuti
che stavamo creando per le persone
che avevano voglia di usufruirne.
Le prime volte che ho iniziato
a raccontare Wikipedia in giro,
quello che raccontavo
era una cosa abbastanza semplice;
dicevo semplicemente
che Wikipedia era un'enciclopedia
e che aveva due sole regole:
la prima regola era rispettare
il diritto d'autore,
perché Wikipedia è rilasciata
con una licenza di copyleft
che rende i suoi contenuti
liberamente riutilizzabili,
e che quindi doveva avere
delle premesse solide
per permettere il riuso
dei suoi contenuti;
e poi dicevo che Wikipedia
non aveva delle regole fisse,
tranne il neutral point of view,
cioè un fine ultimo
cui tendono tutte le voci di Wikipedia,
che vogliono essere neutrali.
Chiaramente, la neutralità non esiste;
ma quello che cerchiamo di fare
è presentare più punti di vista,
tutti quelli che abbiano
una rilevanza enciclopedica
e, nel caso, lasciare la possibilità,
ovviamente, di collezionarli;
chiaro che completezza
non è sinonimo di neutralità,
però è la cosa che più ci si avvicina.
Ma questa era una spiegazione
abbastanza semplicistica
e lasciava adito, come dire,
non a tanti dubbi,
ma lasciava spazio
per tante interpretazioni.
Per cui ad un certo punto,
nella storia di Wikipedia,
si è reso necessario
formalizzare un po' meglio
che cosa fosse Wikipedia
per presentarla meglio.
Quindi sono stati formalizzati
quelli che poi sono stati battezzati
"i cinque pilastri"
perché sono gli elementi
fondanti di Wikipedia.
A parte i due che avevo già raccontato,
il principale è quello che dice
che Wikipedia è un'enciclopedia.
Può sembrare una cosa
abbastanza semplice in se,
e che forse tutti quanti conoscono,
ma in realtà è una definizione ben precisa
che dice esattamente qual è
lo scopo di questo progetto.
Non è una raccolta indiscriminata
di tutte le informazioni presenti in rete,
non ci posso scrivere sopra
qualsiasi cosa mi capiti in testa,
ma sto collaborando ad un progetto
che vuole essere la più grande
enciclopedia al mondo.
Quindi in qualche maniera
questo mi dice già
che ci saranno delle informazioni,
che magari vengono inserite
e poi verranno scartate
secondo alcuni principi
abbastanza semplici
che non esistono a priori,
ma che sono stati stabiliti
sulla base dell'esperienza.
Inizialmente,
su Wikipedia capitavano
un sacco di voci abbastanza insensate,
ma eravamo abbastanza limitati
dalla versione dell'epoca del software
che non ci permetteva neanche
di cancellare le voci,
per cui facevamo degli sforzi incredibili
per andare a rendere
un po' interessanti queste voci.
Io ricordo che una
delle prime voci che ho scritto,
e non in maniera troppo consapevole,
era una voce sulla lingua berbera.
Io non so nulla della lingua berbera,
o meglio non sapevo nulla
della lingua berbera,
non l'ho mai studiata;
però un signore ha scritto "Berbero"
e ha scritto dentro due righe
che non avevano senso.
Io ho preso questa informazione insensata
e l'ha fatta diventare
una micro informazione utile al mondo.
Come l'ho fatto -
documentandomi, come mi hanno insegnato
all'epoca della scuola,
su come si fanno le ricerche.
Wikipedia è anche libera,
ma "Libera" è un termine
che è abbastanza ambiguo,
sia in italiano che in inglese
vuol dire tantissime cose.
La prima libertà di Wikipedia
è quella relativa ai contenuti.
Su Wikipedia sono libera, innanzitutto,
di consultare i suoi
contenuti gratuitamente,
perché Wikipedia non è a pagamento,
non ha pubblicità -
tra l'altro, vive unicamente di donazioni.
Poi sono libera di scrivere su Wikipedia;
ma sono libera, anche,
di modificare i contenuti
che sono stati inseriti da qualcun altro
e sono libera di riutilizzare
anche gli stessi contenuti di Wikipedia
per fare quello che ritengo più opportuno,
perché rispetto semplicemente
le regole della licenza.
Ma Wikipedia è anche libera
perché Wikipedia non ha un capo,
Wikipedia ha una struttura gerarchica
completamente orizzontale,
è un lavoro tra pari.
Poi per rendere questo lavoro
tra pari, come dire, utile e costruttivo
e per non far sì che le stesse discussioni
abbiano luogo sempre
ed in continuazione
e si ripetano sempre le stesse cose,
ci sono una serie
di micro regole che si evolvono
e seguono il corso di Wikipedia,
e sono come dire un codice di condotta.
Quando il codice di condotta
diventa troppo stringente,
troppo pertinente a quello
che sta succedendo in quel momento,
ma che non può diventare una informazione,
come dire, più vasta e più applicabile,
esiste una simpatica regola
che dice "ignora tutte le regole",
perché le regole sono necessarie
fin quando sono uno strumento utile,
ma non devono bloccare
quello che è il tuo lavoro.
La cosa fondamentale
è che Wikipedia fa, crea queste regole
con l'unico strumento
che ha a disposizione,
che è la discussione;
la discussione che, alla fine,
ha bisogno ad un certo
punto di tirare le fila,
e come facciamo?
Noi cerchiamo di evitare
tutte le votazioni,
perché le votazioni tutto sommato
sono uno strumento
che ci arricchisce molto poco,
mentre discutere e confrontare
dei punti di vista
è uno strumento che arricchisce parecchio.
Usiamo il consenso,
significa che portiamo avanti
le discussioni fino ad un certo punto,
in alcuni casi vanno avanti in eterno,
ho in mente discussioni
che sono iniziate, più o meno,
quando io sono arrivata su Wikipedia
e non si sono ancora chiuse,
probabilmente non si chiuderanno a breve.
Ma questo non è come dire, un difetto,
ma un pregio, probabilmente, del progetto.
Quando c'è un'opinione
abbastanza condivisa tra tutti
possiamo dichiarare chiusa
questa discussione.
Le votazioni riguardano
solo, ed unicamente,
delle discussioni, diciamo,
di origine tecnica:
teniamo una voce piuttosto che buttarla,
ma teniamo sempre
a privilegiare il confronto,
perché è l'unica vera cosa arricchente.
Wikipedia nel suo complesso
è un progetto enorme,
che ha tantissimi livelli di lettura.
Può essere vista
come un'enciclopedia generalista,
ma al suo interno può essere
anche vista verticalmente
come una serie di enciclopedie
specialistiche,
perché ci sono delle aree di Wikipedia
che sono veramente vastissime
e veramente ricche
di contenuti molto dettagliati
perché hanno trovato
degli appassionati che la scrivessero
e che curassero in maniera molto certosina
tutte queste informazioni.
In alcuni casi,
Wikipedia è stata vista
come un esperimento di democrazia,
oppure un grande esperimento sociale.
È vero che Wikipedia è tutte queste cose,
ma la cosa principale che è,
e che deve rimanere, è un'enciclopedia.
Quindi il nostro scopo
è scrivere qualcosa che rimanga
e che sia utile ai lettori
e che possano, liberamente,
consultarla e riutilizzarla.
Inizialmente, il progetto
era semplicemente quello di scrivere,
veramente di scrivere un'enciclopedia:
e ci davamo molto dei target numerici.
Per cui, nelle primissime edizioni,
se andate a vedere sulla Way Back Machine,
sulla home page di Wikipedia c'è:
"Vogliamo raggiungere 100.000 voci,
aiutaci a raggiungere questo traguardo"
e dopo 100.000, 250.000,
mezzo milione e via crescendo.
L'edizione inglese di Wikipedia,
in questo momento,
consta di qualche milione di voci.
L'edizione in italiano
si sta avvicinando, piano piano,
al suo primo milione.
Accanto a questi numeri però,
ad un certo punto abbiamo detto:
"sì, va bene, i numeri contano
fino a un certo punto.
Quel che ci interessa è, anche,
di farne qualcosa di più grande".
La prima idea di farne
qualcosa di più grande
è stata di Jimmy Wales,
il fondatore di Wikipedia,
che ha lanciato il progetto
Wikipedia 1.0 e diceva:
"Io voglio stampare Wikipedia
e portarla in Africa
come se fosse un libro di studio,
liberamente utilizzabile da tutti quanti".
Questo aveva però alcuni problemi:
Wikipedia è molto grande, come contenuto,
e mettersi a filtrarne il contenuto
e scegliere che cosa
è corretto stampare, e che cosa no,
è un lavoro abbastanza lungo e complicato.
Poi ha dei costi non indifferenti.
Per cui questo progetto
è stato lentamente accantonato,
anche se, parallelamente,
una versione di Wikipedia
è stata messa sui computer
portati in Africa da Negroponte
e la visione del nostro lavoro
si è ampliata ulteriormente.
La visione attuale che spinge
tutti i volontari che si occupano
di Wikipedia e dei progetti fratelli,
perché Wikipedia è solo uno,
tra nove progetti,
è quello di immaginare un mondo
in cui ogni essere umano abbia accesso
alla somma di tutta la conoscenza,
e vi abbia accesso liberamente,
ed abbia anche la possibilità
di condividere ed arricchire.
Quindi è un obiettivo
incredibilmente grande e vasto
che cerchiamo di raggiungere
portando avanti:
da una parte, delle strategie di crescita;
dall'altra parte,
una seria attenzione alla qualità.
Le strategie di crescita
perché un progetto,
quando è troppo piccolo,
nel marasma di Internet
non riesce a farsi vedere a sufficienza;
e se non si fa vedere a sufficienza,
è difficile che trovi dei volontari
che abbiano voglia di partecipare
e di farlo crescere ulteriormente.
Dall'altra parte,
delle strategie di qualità:
è inutile avere un milione di voci,
se queste voci sono assolutamente
inconsistenti e piene di errori.
Per cui, ad un certo punto
della storia di Wikipedia,
accanto alla crescita
e comunque accanto alla qualità,
che è sempre stata
in qualche maniera controllata,
o comunque un fine
che abbiamo sempre tenuto presente,
c'è stata un'attenzione maniacale
a quello che diciamo essere "le fonti".
È molto importante
che le voci di Wikipedia
cerchino di riportare, sempre,
la fonte di dove è stata presa
quella singola informazione,
perché in questo modo il lettore
può approfondire quello che sta vedendo;
e dall'altra parte
può anche andare a verificare
che quello che c'è scritto
sia assolutamente corretto.
Wikipedia, in questo momento,
è grosso modo il quinto sito
più visitato al mondo.
Tutti i mesi abbiamo, circa,
400 milioni di visitatori unici,
l'edizione italiano ha circa l'1%
dei visitatori che ci sono
nel resto del mondo.
In alcuni casi delle singole voci
raggiungono tantissimi lettori,
di solito per dei fatti che sono
molto attinenti a fatti di cronaca.
Ma il mondo di Wikipedia
è un mondo molto vasto:
non c'è solo Wikipedia,
ci sono altri nove progetti
che si occupano di altre aree del sapere,
che hanno tutte caratteristiche
simili a quelle di Wikipedia,
ma c'è anche una fondazione:
la Wikimedia Foundation è nata
due anni dopo Wikipedia,
quando Wikipedia, ormai,
era un grandissimo progetto.
Nel 2003 è nata Wikimedia Foundation,
che si occupa di sostenere Wikipedia
e di far sì che continui a crescere;
ma non si occupa direttamente
di controllarla,
perché Wikipedia è unicamente
nelle mani della sua comunità,
che discute e decide.
Poi c'è la comunità sovranazionale,
perché alcune cose sono trasversali
a tutte le edizioni di Wikipedia,
in alcuni casi a tutte
le edizioni dei progetti,
quindi non parliamo solo tra di noi,
ma cerchiamo di parlare, anche,
con i nostri colleghi
che si trovano altrove.
Wikipedia, in ogni caso, è un progetto
fatto di persone per le persone.
È uno specchio di quello
che è il nostro mondo.
E lo ha detto benissimo qualche anno fa
il nostro fondatore, Jimmy Wales,
quando in un'intervista gli hanno chiesto
"Come sarà il mondo tra 10 anni?
Come sarà Wikipedia tra 10 anni?"
E lui ha risposto:
"Sarà come sarà il mondo tra 10 anni".
(Applausi)